you make him a statements brought up
against you thirty years later to keep
you out of public office when you might
have grown enormous using human being I
think we need to see civility actually
as a tough-minded virtue that says
picking up on the old Evelyn Beatrice
Hall idea that I may disagree with you
but I'll defend to the death your right
to say it implies two things I'll
respect you enough to say you have a
right to put your ideas on the table and
then the ideas are the issue because
that's where we'll get the best way
forward it's not for me to demonize you
I don't like your ideas but absolutely
you've got the right to put them on the
table let's stretch those out
no it's an unequal playing ground
because that's not the way the games
being played but I don't see any option
and even people like Gandy sort of kind
of got that didn't he I mean it's about
forgiveness that's something that's
washing out of our culture yeah you know
I don't know how relationships ever work
if we can't forgive and I think we have
to be prepared to practice that it's
okay I'm sorry I was offended but that
doesn't matter that's move on rather
than this perpetual audible carry the
offense to the gray mm-hmm and that's
the other great problem we've got in
that culture cuz we even if you can try
and forgive now you can't forget because
social milieu stored up absolutely
everything so that's also the
interesting part is that the asymmetry
of the rules I think is what's becoming
harder and harder for conservatives so
for example Justin Trudeau can show up
in blackface I don't think most people
think he's a true racist by any stretch
he did something stupid it was you know
times change all of those things you
know we've had the governor here Ralph
Northam also you know blackface 30 years
ago but he's a Democrat and the point is
that they're both still in power well we
know if these were conservatives or
Republicans or whatever they would be
destroyed and then so then the source of
that sample well because of that then we
see the Conservatives going no we have
to destroy them too
yeah and that's I think that's the
impulse that you're saying no we have to
fight that impulse yeah III believe
that's right I mean I think there the
other point would be to go to the
frankly the hypocrisy of it and
highlight that but to try and avoid
doing you know the triumphalism
member the lessons when we stopped
burning one another of the stake at the
heart of this unique model of Western
harmony where we learnt to live with one
another's and deepest differences was a
willingness to respect another person's
conscience and let them live truly to
that constants as long as they are not
damaging other people and I don't mean
by that occasionally offending people
this idea that you can't give offense
and that is that that is a way to shut
down debate if ever there was and you
know if I'm honest about my life four
times in which I've grown up in the
times when I've been grossly offended
because somebody else has told me
something about me I haven't wanted to
hear huh yeah and I've had to grow out
of it you know that Johnson heart makes
that point you know we tell our kids we
bring them up to believe that what
doesn't kill you will make you weaker he
says actually if we need to build
resilience and when we get the setbacks
we've got to learn from them and not
just be like a plastic cup that you drop
on the floor and recovers a shape we
actually need to be people when we've
had a setback who'd grow he calls it
antifragility and our parents and
grandparents believe that and look at
what the great generation as you call
them in this country went through so is
that just all then a function of our
success that our parent your right our
parents our grandparents went through at
grandparents particularly at least in an
American context and because of that
because of that grit and fight that then
they sort of got us to unprecedented
wealth a growing middle class in the
United States and what happened well we
got participation trophies yeah other
United right and maybe it took I mean I
grew up with a father who had a
horrendous Second World War
and I was born quite late in his life
and so I always lived with a man had
seen war he volunteered hated it you
know could never talk of it was almost
killed in the campaign against Rommel in
the Western Desert and that's shaped me
but then I'm conscious that I had a
desire with my four children to want a
snowplow for them the tendency was there
I wanted to remove every obstacle in a
way that my father didn't try for me he
knew instinctively that a few challenges
were a good thing for me
and I knew that too but I had to pull
myself back who does the instinct to all
the time was to make it soft and easy
and I think Jonathan Heights right it
doesn't work and he goes on to say that
we then encourage children to trust
their feelings your feelings are always
right we know that's not right you have
to think things through your feelings
must accord with reality it's just
dangerous to feel something's or I feel
that water would be nice and that the
signs saying that there are sharks in
their way of me having a good swim you
know and then the other one this problem
that gets to the heart of what we're
talking about we teach our children that
the dividing line between good and bad
is between people or that bad life is a
battle between good and bad people
that's a disaster it's a disaster yeah
most people on the other side believe
that they're good too they may be
wronged
well not only that we're all the mixture
yeah and why can't we go on a journey
you write quite a bit about how you've
been on a journey politically no well
it's not a good thing you know to think
things through and to learn from your
mistakes
um forgive me it's not for me to say
that you've made mistakes or whatever
but I know I have absolutely made
mistakes I promise you yeah you don't
allowed to know in the lexicon no those
who hold the microphones in our society
and you see that with social media yeah
the thing we're talking about earlier
you make him a statements board up
against you thirty years later to keep
you out of public office when you might
have grown enormously as a human being
and you might have asked those that you
hurt or that you've misjudged okay
whatever mistakes you made for
forgiveness you grow an enormous ear
you've come to a different place why
should we not respect that do you think
oddly though that the end of secularism
leads us to that place of unforgiveness
do you think that is sort of what you
were talking about earlier that if you
remove all of whatever traditional
belief there is that you will end up in
a place that will be so subjective that
how would forgiveness even make sense in
that world that sort of seems to me
where we're when you're sort of that at
the moment yeah I mean this is a great
thing that's all about path everyone
talks about power it's very inadequate
Douglas Murray says it if you walk up to
most people in the street and say what
most matters to you most like when say
power they'll talk about love
talk about relationships over but I
think relationship in the Western model
draws an enormous amount from our
understanding of that thing called the
cross and that the central message there
was a death a life's rendered four
enemies out of love loving your enemies
we can't even love our friends half the
time yeah we need to learn to love our
enemies again which is why I think I'm
all for vigor in debate I love what you
do I love what Jordan Peterson does I
love what so I mean this is a big part
of the picture you've got an enormous
intellectual vigor coming back into
Western life and that's tremendously
encouraging and it's an enormous
privilege just to play a tiny little bit
you know I hope in facilitating that
with my own website for example and so
forth but I say this is tremendously
encouraging but we've got to break the
very model it's brought us to us in the
first boss to that place in the first
place which is the rejection of the idea
of the respect and recognition of the
Worth and dignity of others are you
amazed how this is a truly worldwide
phenomenon right now so that's why I
started the interview by saying that you
know you sent me this email three years
ago and then you know flash-forward
basically two and a half years and I'm
in Australia and I'm doing this event
with you and everyone in that room knew
who I was yeah and now most of them were
there for Jordan I can see that point
but the basic idea that what we're
talking about in America is the same
thing you're talking about in Australia
you're the same thing they're talking
about France they're talking about it in
Mexico it's not purely a Western society
idea anymore it's everywhere no it is it
isn't dude and a couple of observations
mmm the wealthiest countries in
particular where it's been very easy for
a long time have lost sight I think of
the idea of suffering and suffering can
be very instrumental in determining
character and resilience and compassion
for others because you understand
we've got rid of the idea that suffering
you know is part of life we try to
pretend we can build perfect society
which is why people make unreal demands
on government mm-hmm you know we don't
need God or none of that stuff we don't
need suffering anymore so mr.
congressman I expect you to solve every
you'll give me everything give me
everything and mr. congressman has been
unwise enough too often my if there's a
congressman listening police say I could
say exactly the same about what I was or
a senator in Australia we have senators
just like you do we have a wash minster
House of Representatives based on the
British model House of Commons Senate is
modelled exactly on your Senate so we
call it a wash producers ah and we've
just got to break that cycle again and
rediscover some roots or or this is the
one you know can so but he doesn't
believe that the people who have gone
before them were lesser but our culture
now seems to think that those who went
before us have nothing to teach us that
is a fatal flaw if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell